i got a lot of things to do
and i need my memory to do it
rigid i'm old and i seem like i can't
remember nothing no more
i try to say what day it is
ain't got a clue
hey
come on
so you want me to take you to that
special doctor
one of them i could help you remember
things
[Music]
you realize you're coming later no it's
just you and me but reggie do want you
to go see this doctor so
we developed a treatment
mr gray will remember everything that he
has ever known but the treatment will
only work once
is that what you want
i got a lot of things to do
and i need my memory
to do it
there's something in your heart
mr gray
how you feeling never better that's
fat i can see it all
so clear now
my man's whole lifetime just spinning
around in there
my aquaculture
stole
i'm worried about you the rate the
decline is accelerating meaning my mind
gonna be worse than it was the folks
but i got to finish this
you got to let the river take its course
in the river no right where it's going
[Music]
you